Buenos días las instituciones europeas
siguen en shoctas este supuesto caso de
corrupción hoy precisamente los
orientados desde estrasburgo han votado
una resolución con 541 votos a favor en
que han pedido más medidas y más
transparencia para evitar casos
parecidos y han pedido que se paralice
toda legislación que tenga que ver con
Qatar al respecto la presidenta de la
eurocámara Roberta menchola que está
aquí hoy en Bruselas ha anunciado un
gran paquete de medidas para reformar
desde dentro de la institución y la
institución Como por ejemplo proteger a
los informadores en caso de que desvelen
casos de corrupción y también se
prohibirá los grupos no oficiales de
amistad entre eurodiputados y países
para evitar por ejemplo sobornos además
también se prohibirá y se vigilará aún
más grupos de presión que intenten
influir en la legislación europea todo
esto se produce con más informaciones
que se están produciendo ayer Francesco
George y la pareja de la ex
vicepresidenta Eva Kylie declaración
aceptó que participó en esta supuesta
trama de sobornos y además ha apuntado a
más eurodiputados al respecto de todas
maneras no pudo declarar debido a una
huelga de funcionarios en la prisión en
la que se encuentra por lo tanto tendrá
que declarar la semana que viene